So in this lesson, we will go through
several challenges that a many-core
processor, that is a processor with
a very large number of cores, will face.
The first challenge is that as
we grow the number of cores,
the coherence traffic
between these cores goes up.
And that is because we have already seen
that writes to shared memory locations.
Resulting in validations and
subsequent misses on those locations.
And both invalidations and the resulting
misses go onto the shared bus,
and thus, add to this coherent traffic.
As we increase the number of cores,
we get more writes per second.
And, as a result,
the bus throughput that we need goes up,
until it eventually exceeds
what we can do on a bus.
Unfortunately, the bus allows us
to only do one request at a time.
In part, that is needed because
we rely on the bus to produce
the easy ordering that we get
between rides to maintain coherence.
But that means that really the bus
eventually becomes the bottleneck.
So, what we need is
a scalable on-chip network
that allows the traffic to grow
as the number, of course, grows.
And then we also need to
use directory coherence so
that we don't rely on the bus
to serialize everything for us.